[Applaudissements]
dans quelques instants les momies de
l'egypte ancienne
ce sont ces corps enveloppés dans des
linceuls qui ont aidé à inspirer et
définir les bases du culte religieux les
gens de l'époque semblait en apparence
préoccupé par la mort mais en réalité
c'est la vie qu'ils recherchaient
le nil nous permet de découvrir une
civilisation perdue centré sur
l'immortalité
on peut voir la dernière de sept
merveilles du monde
les pyramides de gizeh
et puis on continue à travers le
labyrinthe des passages qui protégeait
les défunts et leur permettait
d'atteindre l'au delà
on peut ensuite regarder le visage de
cette impressionnante masse silencieuse
où l'homme se mélange à l'animal le
sphinx retournons à l'époque des
pharaons alors que le sphinx et le
plateau de gizeh reprennent vie grâce à
la technologie moderne
ensuite nous pouvons découvrir le
mystère des hiéroglyphes
ces inscriptions sacrés sont les
instructions nécessaires à la momie afin
qu'elles puissent mener à bien son
passage dans l'au delà
découvrons ce dont on avait besoin pour
ce passage dans un des trésors les plus
impressionnants qu'on n'ait jamais
trouver la tombe de toutankhamon
on peut ensuite voir la dernière
extraction des années 1990 la tonte que
l'on connaît sous le sigle car v5
tournons-nous regard vers le passé dans
un univers où la nature humaine la magie
et le mystère se rencontrent découvrons
les momies et les secrets des cryptes
égyptienne
[Musique]
les pyramides et le sphinx
les hiéroglyphes
[Musique]
les momies
l'egypte
[Musique]
on a vu se développer ici une puissante
civilisation et ses habitants ont essayé
d'exprimer leurs remerciements envers
leurs dieux le nil pour voiliers aux
nécessités de la vie alors que le désert
offrait une certaine protection
au cours de son développement l'egypte
ancienne et establet prenait le temps de
créer de prospérer et de réfléchir à
l'existence humaine
le style utilisé par l'egypte ancienne
et facilement reconnaissable
ces trésors représentent des indices
concrets menant secret d'un passé
lointain et permettant ainsi la
découverte de l'egypte ancienne
c'était le domaine des pharaons dans la
vallée du nil
ils ont fait des constructions marquée
des inscriptions qui ont permis à la
religion et à la philosophie de se
développer
c'est ainsi que l'egypte a profondément
influencé en europe le domaine dollars
et celui des sciences
cette vallée du nil entouré de désert
représentent le coeur de l'egypte
ancienne
stine helen poule historien auteur 1892
l'histoire de l'egypte ancienne et
ramper d'ingénuité l'imagination se
mélange à la pensée la religion est
entre la cde mythologie et les idées
abstraites forme le monde de la réalité
[Musique]
la culture égyptienne se repose sur une
croyance mystérieuse qui prend fermement
racines dans l'inconnu les monuments la
protéger les statuts la symbolisait les
inscriptions secrète l'expliquer les
trésors lui apportait la sécurité
mais c'était la momie qu'il a
personnifié
la momie représente l arme de guerre
principal des égyptiens il s'était
engagé contre leur propre mortalité et
c'est une lutte qui durerait aussi
longtemps que leur civilisation
l'évolution a commencé durant l'époque
prédynastique ou pour des raisons
pratiques on enterrait les défunts loin
des terrains fertiles
les premiers ensevelissement ne montre
aucun effort de préservation on
enterrait simplement le défunt dans du
sable
la sécheresse naturel du sable déserté
contre la peau a ainsi permis de
préserver l'apparence humaine du défunt
cette préservation durera pendant des
milliers d'années à moins de subir une
intrusion externe
lorsque l'on enterre les gens pour la
plupart dans des tombeaux de sable les
corps sont faciles à déterrer et les
animaux sauvages viennent chercher de la
nourriture dans la nécropole après la
mort du grand père vous revenez sur la
tombe et vous découvrez qu'il a été
déterré et est étendu à l'extérieur vous
regardant il avait l'impression que le
grand-père existait temps que son corps
était toujours là les égyptiens se sont
intéressés au processus de conservation
naturelle en essayant tout d'abord de
l'expliquer puis en essayant de limiter
c'est là que la préparation funéraire a
commencé les premiers efforts pour
préserver le corps du défunt ont eu lieu
au tout début de l'époque dynastique
environ 3000 ans avant jésus-christ on a
retrouvé des fragments de corps qui
avaient été soigneusement enveloppé il
semblerait qu'à l'époque on n'avait
aucune idée de ce qui se passait après
l'ensevelissement et les gens pensaient
qu en enveloppant le corps ce dernier
serait préservée
les premiers essais de préservation ont
échoué le secret de la momification
naturel reposait sur le processus de
déshydratation causées par l'effet du
soleil et du sable au contact de la peau
mais si le corps était enveloppé il ne
pouvait plus et chez et se décomposait
c'est à cette époque là qu'ils ont
commencé à développer le processus de
momification artificielle la
préservation du corps était extrêmement
importante
il pensait qu'une fois décédé une
personne pouvait se diviser en plusieurs
parties la première partie était le
corps physique et la seconde le double
spirituelle de la personne ou qu'à la
troisième partie était représenté par la
personnalité du défunt qui est souvent
symbolisé dans les reliefs par un oiseau
à tête humaine quand ces différentes
parties sans forme précise reconnaissait
votre configuration générale voilà elle
se remettait ensemble pour permettre la
transformation finale
une sorte de résurrection finale dans
l'au delà
cette transformation finale permettait
aux bas et au cas une fois réunies de
devenir ce que les égyptiens appelé m ac
c'est à dire un être de lumière
glorifier
[Musique]
pour les egyptiens la momification était
essentiel pour le défunt afin de pouvoir
compléter la transformation finale
il espérait préserver le corps physique
grâce à un processus artificielle et le
corps spirituel grâce à des prières et
des offrandes
si tout était fait de façon exacte il
pensait que la personne pouvait vivre
indéfiniment
une industrie entière se développer à
partir de ce besoin de préserver le
corps humain dans l'egypte ancienne la
momification était un commerce de grande
importance si vous ne pouviez pas être
préservés alors de toute évidence vous
ne pouviez pas être ressuscitée vous
perdiez votre existence et vous ne
pouviez pas parvenir à l'au delà
les égyptiens ne possédait pas de
concepts tels que l'enfer après la mort
ou ont continué son existence on se
retrouvait sans existence la
momification est une profession
distinctes lorsqu on leur apporte le
corps du défunt les embaumeurs utilisent
des échantillons de statuettes en bois
qui sont peintes de façon naturelle
il explique que les statuettes de plus
grande qualité et qui sont les plus
chères ressemble à un être dont je ne
peux mentionner le nom
la deuxième catégorie de statuettes est
un peu inférieure et moins coûteuse et
la troisième est la moins chère de
toutes
après avoir montré la différence de
qualité il demande laquelle on choisit
et les parents du défunt après s'être
entendues sur le prix partent et laisse
les embaumeurs faire leur travail
hérode historien grec 450 avant
jésus-christ
le magasin des embaumeurs était appelée
la tante de purification c'est là que le
processus le plus élaboré de
momification avait lieu
c'était un procédé qui prenait 70 jours
et qui commençait par la déshydratation
du corps la modification artificielle
repose essentiellement sur la
déshydratation
la première étape consistait à enlever
tous les viscères du corps du défunt
la personne appelée scribe marqué sur le
flanc gauche l'étendue de l'incision
[Musique]
la personne appelée barragiste faisait
l'incision avec une pierre éthiopienne
et s'enfuyait alors que ceux présents le
poursuivait tout en lui lançant des
pierres et en le maudissant car aux yeux
de tous ceux qui faisaient violence à un
accord de la même tribu devenait l'objet
d'une haine générale les personnes
appelées embaumeur sont cependant
considéré comme honorable quand ils se
sont tous rassemblés autour du corps
pour le traité après avoir procédé alain
cision uns d'entre eux met sa main à
l'intérieur du cadavre
diodore historien grec 59 avant
jésus-christ grâce à une incision
abdominale une très petite incision
abdominale on enlevait le foie les reins
et les intestins parce qu'ils
contenaient un certain taux d'humidité
et il fallait se débarrasser de
l'humidité
après cela ils remplissaient la cavité
avec de la mire de la plus haute qualité
avec de la cannelle casse et toutes
sortes dépis sauf de l'encens hérodote
historien grec 450 avant jésus-christ on
enlevait aussi le cerveau ce qui
représentait la chose la plus difficile
et celle pour laquelle les égyptiens
sont célèbres
cela se faisait grâce une incision fait
sur le nez il pénétrait le nez est cassé
l'os appelé est moïse qui se trouve
derrière les yeux de façon à atteindre
le cerveau
ensuite à l'aide d'un crochet glisser à
l'intérieur ils enlevaient petit à petit
le cerveau
[Musique]
après avoir enlevé les organes le corps
étaient traités pendant les 35 jours
suivants dans un affront qui agissait
comme agent de déshydratation et qu'ils
aient trouvé naturellement en egypte il
s'agit d'un mélange de bicarbonate de
soude et de sel ensuite on procédait au
reste du rite
il y avait aussi un aspect spirituel à
la momification
alors que les embaumeurs étaient les
techniciens il y avait aussi un groupe
de prêtres qui faisait office pendant le
rite de la momification les prêtres
vêtus de façon étrange murmuraient des
formules magiques destinée à assurer le
passage du défunt dans l'au-delà au un
mot doux parfum de grand dieu tu
contient un parfum tels que ton visage
ni ne changera ni nos dirigeants
après savoir dit quelques paroles
magiques on passait au ban de laitages
le corps d hydrater et découvert d'un
mélange d'huile et des pis on appliquer
ensuite une couche protectrice pour
éviter l'humidité les premiers visiteurs
en egypte pensait que cette substance
était de la mi-mars à un mélange d'huile
provenant de perth
c'est de cette erreur que découle le mot
momies des incantations accompagnait
également cette partie du rituel
acorn aucune respiration puisse
traverser la tête du défunt dans l'au
delà et qu'il puisse voir de ses yeux et
entendre de ses oreilles
qu'il puisse respirer par l'eau mais qui
puisse produire des sons avec sa bouche
et qu'il y puise parler la langue de
l'eau de la formule de l'egypte ancienne
la momie était le résultat de la
mythologie égyptienne aussi rice le roi
des défunts et est considéré comme le
premier occidental
c'était la résurrection légendaire de
son corps qui a amené la croyance de la
vie après la mort
osiris est devenue le symbole de la
résurrection
il y a beaucoup de différences dans la
manifestation de cette croyance suivant
les époques les classes sociales mais
c'est la croyance qui la plus importante
la croyance en la vie après la mort elle
est considérée comme une vérité par
toute la population à travers toutes les
périodes de la religion égyptienne
le soleil et les cultes solaires sont
aussi les éléments cruciaux
cela donnait aux égyptiens la garantie
et laisse croire qu'il pourrait toujours
renaître en liant leur côté psychique au
cycle solaire
dans la profondeur de la nuit le soleil
rejoint osiris et possédant le pouvoir
de régénérer il reçoit aussi le pouvoir
de résurrection de façon à traverser
l'au delà et à conquérir tous les
dangers qu il y rencontre pour
finalement revenir à la vie le matin
suivant le concept égyptien de la vie
après la mort et est similaire pour tous
les humains
le corps devait surmonter les mêmes
obstacles que le soleil c'était un
processus que le défunt devait suivre
tous les jours
c'est donc pour cela que la momification
était nécessaire parce que la momie
représentait pour le défunt ce que la
momie cosmique d'osiris représentait
pour le soleil cet incident de communion
un site où vous trouvez le pouvoir de
revenir à la vie
[Musique]
dans l'egypte ancienne la momification
ne suffisait pas à assurer l'immortalité
il fallait aussi protéger la momie c'est
dans ce but que les égyptiens ont conçu
des monuments qui font partie des
constructions les plus remarquables au
monde
[Musique]
ces constructions sont les dernières de
sept merveilles du monde a su remonter
le temps elles représentent des symboles
durable qui illumine les pages de
l'histoire ce sont les pyramides de
gizeh
ah ah
leur époque était marquée dans pire qui
ont disparu elles ont vu des
civilisations que nous n'avons jamais
connu
elles ont compris des langues que nous
essayons de déchiffrer grâce à des
hiéroglyphes
elles ont connu des coutumes qui nous
apparaissent aussi magique qu'un rêve
cela fait si longtemps qu'elle existe
que les étoiles ont changé de coordonner
dans le ciel
[Musique]
théophile gautier écrivain français 1869
elle émerge du désert comme des navires
dans un océan de sable
ce panorama a toujours suscité et
continue à susciter l'étonnement
c'est leur couleur qui surprend les
visiteurs peu d'entre eux savent
auparavant que le ton show de la pierre
et gilles sienne provient des années
d'exposition sous le soleil brûlant de
l'egypte à certains moments les
pyramides apparaissent comme des piles
d'or massif à milliards us égyptologue
université de londres
[Musique]
les pyramides de gizeh semble nous avoir
jeté un sort car les scientifiques ne
trouve pas les secrets
il est impossible d'imaginer que des
humains aient pu créer quelque chose de
si imposant de ces innovateurs et d'une
telle complexité structurale en fait
cela semble tellement impossible qu'on a
même attribué la construction à des
extraterrestres
cependant ces monuments ont été créée
par des êtres humains des êtres humains
qui étaient décidés à continuer leur
style de vie tout au long de l'éternité
l'humanité a peur du temps et le temps a
peur des pyramides proverbe arabe
les pyramides de gizeh étaient des
tombes royales elle faisait partie des
préparations funéraire de l'egypte
ancienne
les tombes sont entre autres appelée
maison de l'éternité
puisque les gens pensaient que leur mort
serait plus longue que leur vie sur
terre ils voulaient perpétuer leur
existence alors que ce soit une pyramide
ou un mastaba que ce soit une tombe fait
de pierres taillées ou un tombeau de
sable dans le désert les égyptiens
voulaient continuer à vivre leur vie
[Musique]
il y à plus de 4000 ans les pyramides et
est tout aussi importante puisqu'elle
était destiné à protéger les corps des
pharaons défunt
[Musique]
les pyramides symbolise le point
culminant d'une idéologie qui s'était
développée sur plusieurs centaines
d'années il y a quelque chose de curieux
chez ces pyramides
plus on les regarde plus elles
deviennent impressionnante gustave
flaubert voyageurs en egypte 1849
au cours de l'histoire on a attribué à
ces constructions massives des pouvoirs
mystérieux et magique
cependant si les pyramides de gizeh
possède des pouvoirs particuliers
c'est grâce à l'imagination humaine et
non grâce à un autre type d'intervention
c'est la recherche désespérée des
égyptiens dans le but de trouver des
réponses à leurs questions qui les a
entraînés à chercher une signification
de part et d'autre et même dans un amas
de roches à forme pointue
personne ne se réveille un matin en se
disant tiens la pyramide un aspect
magique elle va avoir des pouvoirs
extraordinaires
c'est en réalité un développement
architectural qui a pris plusieurs
centaines d'années
on est passé de simple tombeau de sable
à des structures connues sous le nom de
mastaba l'homo mastaba signifie banc en
arabe cela rappelle la forme aplatie de
la tombe ressemblant à un morceau de
gâteau ils sont similaires à des banques
que l'on peut trouver à l'extérieur de
maisons villageoises moderne
c'est une structure rectangulaire
ressemblant à une maison en fait dans
l'egypte ancienne on en parlait comme
d'une maison une maison d'éternité dans
un mastaba la tombe est une pièce au
sous-sol à laquelle on parvient par un
long couloir verticale le corps du
défunt est reposé l'accès est supprimée
en remplissant le couloir de pierres
pendant la troisième dynastie en 2006
ans avant jésus-christ la conception des
tons va changer quand le roi jazz air a
commandé la construction de son tombeau
un architecte du nom d' hypothèse a mis
tout son ingénuité à construire la
première pyramide égyptienne
la pyramide à degrés de saqqara
imhotep a décidé de placer un mastaba au
dessus d'un mastaba ce qui a donné pour
résultat une structure à plusieurs
niveaux à laquelle les égyptiens ont
plus tard accorder une grande valeur la
forme pyramidal consistait
essentiellement à obtenir une certaine
hauteur dans une société préindustrielle
de la sorte si vous voulez construire
quelque chose d'élever et vous n'avez
pas de structure en acier
il vous faut de la superposition ce qui
donne un genre de piles massive la
construction de ces structures massives
repose essentiellement sur la stabilité
de l'ensemble
les scientifiques pensent que ce
principe fait partie intégrante de
l'évolution idéologique du principe de
construction
il affirme que c'est la raison pour
laquelle on trouve des pyramides dans le
monde
contrairement à un point de vue moderne
les égyptiens de l'époque ont vu plus
qu'une construction de grande taille
dans la forme des pyramides
ils ont aussi vu un certain pouvoir et
un aspect symboliquement magique
les égyptiens croyait que l'univers
commençait par une colline qui s'était
élevé des eaux chaotique
cette idée était issu des inondations
annuelles en egypte lorsque les eaux se
retirait les collines s'en détachaient
et il y avait de l'eau tout autour
d'elle
selon la légende un lotus à boussé sur
la colline principal est le dieu soleil
en a émergé et du dieu soleil à émerger
toute création pour les égyptiens la
pyramide représente le petit tas de
terre que l'on fait quand on plante une
graine la momie du roi qui se trouve
dans les profondeurs de la pyramide et
comme une graine qui attend de retourner
à la vie et la pyramide et dans un sens
le tas de terre qui lui donne la
possibilité de revivre
la pyramide à degrés a introduit une
nouvelle étape dans la construction des
tombes pour les pharaons égyptiens
mais pendant 200 ans on y fera des
améliorations continuelles et le
résultat a donné une des sept merveilles
du monde
les pyramides de gizeh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant de bâtir les pyramides de gizeh
les égyptiens ont accru leurs
connaissances en matière de construction
de pyramide pendant une période de deux
cents ans
ils ont fait des développements
impressionnant dans l'architecturé et la
valeur des pyramides
c'est un ensemble de merveilles qui
troublent l'esprit plus on les regarde
plus elle nous inspire de l'admiration
adèle latif médecins arabes 1200 à d
avec le temps les pyramide à degrés ont
adopté un aspect plus lisse pendant une
des étapes de progression architectural
les égyptiens ont comblé les paliers ce
changement de style a donné une nouvelle
signification à 7 ans de monumental la
pyramide est un symbole solaire associée
à l'origine avec les étoiles et peu
après associé au lever et coucher du
soleil comme on le remarque dans la
transition entre les pyramide à degrés
de joe sert à saqqarah et les pyramides
du plateau de guizeh les experts
affirment également que la forme
pyramidale est une représentation
symbolique de la structure sociale de
l'egypte ancienne la base symbolise les
masses et puis on se dirige vers le haut
en traversant les différentes couches
sociales
lorsque l'on arrive en haut de la
pyramide il y à une pièce unique qui
représente la puissance du pharaon
que les yeux fortifie les rayons du
soleil afin que vous puissiez montées
aux yeux quand l'ordre est terrestre
religieux l'égide ans les pyramides de
gizeh font partie des monuments les plus
extraordinaires de tous les temps
s'étonnant montagne de pierres n'ont pas
d'équivalent en taille et stature elle
nous rappelle un monde perdu ou la peur
et l'espoir ont inspiré les humains a
créé avec grandeur elles ont été
construites au dans l'histoire
égyptienne pendant la ivème dynastie la
période de l'ancien empire remontant à
environ 2500 avant jésus-christ elles
ont été construites à un moment où
peut-être la technique de construction
des pyramides était à son sommet et
finalement elles ont été connues à cause
des trois rois qui les ont construites
[Musique]
la plus petite des trois avaient reçu
son nom de me thierry nuss que les grecs
appelaient mykérinos la moyenne dont le
sommet est endommagée appartenait à cas
fera que les grecs appelaient képhren et
qui était le père de même corée
et il ya la grande pyramide celle de
qufu que les grecs appelaient khéops le
père de khephren et le grand-père
domaine corée elles forment ensemble une
chaîne étonnante s'est toujours faite
par des humains domine par leurs auteurs
leur aspect massif a depuis toujours
attiré les curieux au cours des siècles
de nombreux voyageurs ont insisté à
monter un des trois escaliers pour
essayer de capturer la magie du moment
c'était comme si on pouvait en un
instant se retrouver une auteur
remarquable au delà du temps et regarder
deux siècles est allé à nos pieds à
milhas et drugs égyptologue université
de londres
1877 ces constructions humaines étaient
faites pour durer pendant toute
l'éternité et jusqu'à présent c'est
exactement ce qu'elles ont fait
soldats du sommet de ces dix stands
pyramide quatre siècles vous regarde
napoléon à son expédition militaire 1798
au cours des siècles
la construction de ces pyramides a posé
une et nine elle serait même aujourd'hui
un ouvrage extraordinaire mais elle
était bien plus particulièrement pour
l'antiquité
il est difficile d'imaginer les
égyptiens de l'époque calculant leur
mesure avec une telle précision mais
c'est exactement ce qu'ils ont fait les
côtés des pyramides forme de triangle
parfait
[Musique]
comment les égyptiens ont-ils taille et
transporter toutes les pierres au
plateau de guizeh cela demeure un
mystère
il n'avait ni animaux domestiques ni
roux assez fort pour porter de tels
poids mais cependant ils y sont parvenus
nous avons des inscriptions monumentale
des textes officiels des archives
provenant de temples mais nous n'avons
qu'une lettre individuelle de gens qui
auraient participé dans le travail de
transport des pierres et la construction
des pyramides
cela nous aurait beaucoup aidé les
pyramides de gizeh sont symboliques pour
les gens de l'époque mais tout autant
pour la société moderne
elle nous rappelle une époque où l'on
pouvait demander aux gens de construire
des images pour leurs dirigeants
c'est montagne artificielle nous donne
un aperçu du génie rocky pour mener à
bien leur construction et de la
détermination humaines nécessaires
après tout on pense qu'elles ont été
construites grâce à une main d'oeuvre
illimité un nombre sans fin de personnes
prêtes à travailler jusqu'à ce que le
travail soit fini
les théories sur leurs constructions
varient certains experts pensent que les
ouvriers étaient équipés de harnais
tirant ainsi à l'aide de plaques des
blocs de pierre sur une surface mouillée
de façon à pouvoir glisser
il aurait donc continuer ce processus
jusqu'à ce que la pyramide soit au
niveau désiré
d'autres experts pensent qu'un genre de
support comportant des plateformes
entouraient la pyramide ce qui aurait
permis aux équipes d'ouvriers de mettre
en place les pierres les plus lourdes
au delà du procédé de construction des
pyramides
la question la plus énigmatique reste
celle de savoir qui les a construites à
travers les âges
on a attribué la construction à des
esclaves mais les égyptologues ont un
tout autre point de vie j'ai tendance à
considérer les pyramides non comme un
énorme projet de construction faite par
des esclaves où tout le monde travaille
dans la douleur et la torture mais comme
un projet de construction nationale où
tout le monde participe en soutenant
l'ordre établi pour garantir l'après vie
du roi en construisant sept ensembles
funéraires
vous faites un projet national qui
assurent la prospérité de la culture
entière
[Musique]
il s'agissait d' énormes projets
particulièrement durant les périodes où
le nil déborder sur ses rives
il y avait de nombreux cultivateurs sans
emploi il devait donc compenser les
impôts non payés par des heures de
travail alors que d'autres travailler à
plein temps mais je pense qu'il y avait
aussi des mobilisés pour aider à
extraire et à tailler les blocs de
pierres ainsi qu'elle est placée
ce n'était donc pas de l' esclavage
c'était une solution économique pour que
les gens puissent garder leur emploi au
sud des pyramides de gizeh on a fait
récemment une découverte qui vient
soutenir les idées établies par de
nombreux experts en 1987 un ancien
cimetière a été découvert par une
personne qui passait à cheval ce site
est connu sous le nom de village des
ouvriers à cet endroit il y avait une
série de tombes placées les unes à côté
des autres
à l'ombre des pyramides ce site n'est
placé qu'un kilomètre et demi des
survivants spirituel de la septième
merveille ce qui amenait les experts à
établir une théorie il affirme que des
tombes pour esclaves n'aurait pas été
placée si près du pharaon et les
esclaves n'aurait pas eu des pierres
d'une telle valeur pour construire leur
propre monument éternel le côté unique
de ce site se trouve dans les tombes en
briques de boue séchée qui existe vous
remarquerez que ces gens ont utilisé des
tombes en briques faite de morceaux de
calcaire de basalte et de granit
provenant de restes de construction de
la pyramide
ce qui est intéressant dans ce cimetière
c'est la présence d'au moins six types
de tombes
ces gens ont imité les rois en
construisant de façon similaire aux
pyramides des plafonds de tombeau à
voûtes et même des tombes en forme de
pyramide à degrés
les experts pensent qu'à un moment donné
plus de dix mille personnes habiter et
sont morts à cet endroit
il pense que ces gens étaient les
artistes et les artisans qui avaient
aidé à la construction de la pyramide
ils affirment que leurs différentes
professions apparaissent de manière
évidente dans la beauté des inscriptions
hiéroglyphique la structure complexe à
créative de leurs tombes
est ce qu'il reste des défunts à
l'endroit même on remarque que tous les
squelettes trouvés dans ce cimetière
possédait les mêmes problèmes dorsaux
parce qu'il devait soulever des poids
énorme
le poids des pierres avaient peut être
endommagé les corps des égyptiens de
l'antiquité mais il n'a pas pu détruire
leur croyance en l'au delà
malgré les années de travail ils se sont
tout de même construit des tombeaux pour
eux mêmes ainsi que le monument massif
en pierre dédié à leroy
[Musique]
quand enfin on atteint les limites du
désert le sol s'élevant vers un plateau
rocheux et que la grande pyramide
majestueuse nous surprend nous dominant
de sa hauteur l'effet est aussi soudain
qu'étonnant le ciel est l'horizon
s'éclipse ainsi que les autres pyramide
tout disparaît et nous laisse ses bailly
émerveillé à milliards us en 1877
[Musique]
pour ce qui est de la grande pyramide de
qufu 2 millions 300 mille pierre dont le
poids est environ de 2 tonnes et demie
chacune couvre une aire de 48 1564 m² et
s'élève à plus de 137 mètres de hauteur
[Musique]
à l'origine cette pyramide s'élevait à
près de 147 mètres de haut avant que le
temps ne laisse son empreinte
[Musique]
on sait que les blocs de pierre situé
sur la partie externe ont été enlevés il
ya environ 500 ans pour construire des
mosquées et des pas les arabes mais
l'aspect de roche rugueuse de l'escalier
géant nous surprend cependant il n'a pas
l'air d'une rue ou partielle et on
dirait que les ouvriers vont revenir
demain matin pour continuer leur travail
amelia et drugs 1877
la pyramide de qufu est plus haute que
la statue de la liberté
le taj mahal et la basilique saint
pierre c'était la construction la plus
haute du monde jusqu'à la construction
de la tour eiffel en 1889
cependant sa taille n'est pas
essentiellement en rapport avec sa
fonction
on l'a construite de grande taille pour
le pharaons de l'egypte ancienne
non pour la religion égyptienne de
l'époque on peut retracer le
développement de la pyramide du point de
vue historique du stade de tas de terre
mis sur les tombeaux à décoller une plus
grande mise sur les tombes des rois
jusqu'à finalement obtenir la grande
pyramide de gizeh qui est la colline la
plus grande jamais construite par des
humains
toutes ces constructions le même but et
la même fonction pour les égyptiens de
l'antiquité elle aurait fonctionné de la
même façon et donc la taille est plus en
rapport avec le concept de fierté
personnelle que tout autre chose
l'orientation de la construction
auraient pu être secondaire quand on
considère l'objectif essentiel de la
pyramide
mais pour ajouter un effet magique il
était impératif que l'entrée soit du
côté nord
la porte de la pyramide est aligné avec
les étoiles circumpolaire que les gens
de l'antiquité appelait les
indestructibles
ce sont les étoiles qui n'ont jamais
l'air de bouger qui sont éternels et
donc représente l'endroit parfait où le
pharaon peut terminer son voyage le
tombeau du roi à un thème plus cosmique
parce que la famille du roi à des
préoccupations plus cosmique
car il dirige la nation entière
le roy assure le lien entre les dieux et
le peuple il émit dieu amy mortels
le roi devait atteindre l'au-delà la
civilisation égyptienne de l'époque en
dépendait pour assurer le bon
déroulement de son voyage
ils ont construit un labyrinthe de
passage qui est encore de nos jours
énigmatique
pour l'égypte ancienne le pharaon était
un demi dieu et 1/2 mortels il était la
représentation du dieu horus
horus était le fils d'osiris il était
aussi le dieu des vivants en tant
qu'être vivant le roi était responsable
du maintien de l'ordre de la
civilisation de l'antiquité les
égyptiens ne voyait pas le cosmos comme
soumis à des lois naturelles créant un
équilibre général
leur concept du cosmos demandait des
efforts importants et une des fonctions
du roi était de s'assurer de façon
quotidienne qu'il n'y ait pas d'
anéantissement possible du monde les
responsabilités du pharaon ne s'arrêtait
pas à sa mort le roi au russe devait se
transformer et changer pour devenir
osiris
[Musique]
le pharaon roi des défunts continuerait
à veiller de l'au-delà sur les problèmes
terrestre pour éviter tout cas au son
voyage jusqu'à l'au-delà devait être
menée à bien
l'intérieur et l'extérieur des pyramides
et est donc conçu dans ce but là la
grande pyramide a provoqué une véritable
guerre archéologiques
on a passé des années à l'étudier à la
mesure et à y percer des trous en
spéculant sur le placement des pierres
et en inventant des théories au sujet de
l'objectif de la construction charles
daudelin one archéologues 1884
[Musique]
dans la grande pyramide de qufu l'entrée
des passagers liée aux étoiles avant de
mener à un long tunnel d'une largeur de
1 m 22 et d'une hauteur de 92 cm
ce couloir semble ne pas laisser passer
l'air et de ne pas en finir
après être monté à 97 mètres et demi il
donne sur une pièce sombre et qui n'a
pas été terminé
[Musique]
il n'y a pas d'autres endroits au monde
plus profondément enfouie dans la roche
plus sombre que les pièces situées en
dessous des grandes pyramides
si vous y êtes à midi vous êtes séparé
de la lumière du monde autant que cela
soit possible dans ce sens là les pièces
internes et les passages de la pyramide
ressemble à la terre
la pièce souterraine était à l'origine
destiné à la momie du pharaon
elle devait servir de collines pour
couvrir le roi dont le corps était une
graine qui devait pousser pour retrouver
la vie mais quelque chose s'est passé
selon les scientifiques la raison pour
laquelle ce travail a été abandonnée
aurait pu résulter d'un développement de
type religieux
il affirme que c'est durant la
construction de cette pyramide que le
roi a décidé que sa momie devrait être
enterré non seulement dans un combo mais
aussi dans un sarcophage de pierre placé
à l'intérieur du tombeau
le sarcophage portait le nom de m
inc c'est à dire possesseurs de la vie
quand le roi reposait dans son
sarcophage qui était de pierre et
symbolisait la terre
c'était comme s'il était remis dans le
ventre de sa mère appelée nout et qui
était la déesse du ciel en d'autres
termes c'était pour lui comme s'il
reconnaissait dans le ciel à ce niveau
social l'élément cosmique étant présent
on voit que les égyptiens considéré la
tombe comme le ventre de la mère
leroy surmontait la mort en renaissant
dans le ciel et dans l'au-delà où se
trouvait le domaine d'osiris toutes ces
idées s'entrelacent est dans la pensée
égyptienne sans créer d'impression
contradictoires
le sarcophage de pierre était un moyen
supplémentaire d'assurer le passage du
pharaon dans l'au delà
mais dans le cas de la grande pyramide
cela présentait un problème
cet objet lourd et de grande taille ne
pourrait pas passer dans les couloirs
jusqu'à la chambre funéraire
on peut voir aujourd'hui où les ouvriers
travaillaient peut-être un matin et puis
se sont arrêtés l'après midi il savait
décidé d'adapter leurs projets et de
mettre la chambre funéraire au coeur de
la pyramide
ce qui n'avait jamais été fait
auparavant ils ont donc fait un passage
à travers les pierres déjà mises en
place
[Musique]
ce tunnel s'élève à 38 mètres avant
d'atteindre le niveau où se trouve la
chambre de la reine un non attribués à
tort à la pièce par des visiteurs arabes
qui trouvait qu'elle ressemblait aux
tombes réservé aux fans de l'époque
[Musique]
la chambre de la reine comme la chambre
souterraine avait aussi été abandonnée
sans la finir encore une fois le
sarcophage semble en avoir été la raison
certains experts pensent qu'il n'avait
pas été terminé à temps alors les
ouvriers ont continué leur travail
quel endroit sombre et déprimant nos
visages sentait ses terres étouffant
surchauffée pendant cinq mille ans par
le soleil qui brillait sur la pyramide
jusqu'à lui donner l'apparence d'une
fournaise james hendry président
fondateur de l'institut oriental à
l'université de chicago 1905 la pyramide
de qufu continuer à s'élever
on ne peut mentionner cette structure
massive sans inclure la grande galerie
[Musique]
la transpiration coule sur nos visages
alors que nous nous reposons nous sommes
en haut du grand couloir et nous le
regardons content d'avoir pu en
atteindre le sommet ce qui n'est pas
chose facile
james hendry brest et 1905
ce passage d'une longueur de 47 mètres
donne dans une pièce de granit rouge
réservé à la tombe du pharaon
[Musique]
au fond de la pièce se trouve le
sarcophage de granit du roi qui était à
l'origine de la construction de la
grande pyramide
il mesure environ deux mètres de long et
un peu plus de 92 cm de large
c'est là où l'on pense qu'un des plus
grands dirigeants sur terre a dormi
le roi de ce qui était à l'époque le
plus grand royaume du monde
le mortel remplit de fierté pour qui
cette structure majestueuse avait été
construite
john lloyd stevens auteurs voyageurs
[Musique]
les dimensions de ce sarcophage ont fait
l'objet d'études
elles sont intéressantes parce qu'elle
montre que le sarcophage est trop grand
pour pouvoir passer par l'entrée de la
pièce les experts ont donc conclu qu on
a dû lui mettre durant la construction
de la pyramide au coeur de la pyramide
est devant nous se trouve le sarcophage
dans lequel le roi a été enseveli on
peut voir que des voleurs en ont cassé
un des coins à la recherche d'un trésor
le corps du défunt a été enlevé de son
tombeau
james hendry braastad 1905
après le décès du pharaon sa momie
seraient placés dans le sarcophage
mais il lui faudrait ressuscité et
sortir de la pyramide puisque la chambre
funéraire se trouvait au centre de la
construction
on avait donc peur que le pharaon ne
puisse pas trouver l'entrée principale
[Musique]
les égyptiens ont compris que cela
allait être un problème
alors ils ont conçu un couloir verticale
partant de la face nord de la grande
pyramide de façon à ce que l'âme du roi
puisse aller aux cieux les égyptiens
pensaient qu'il fallait un équilibre
artistique et architectural ils ont donc
construit un autre couloir verticale
dans le mur sud de qufu tout comme il
l'avait fait du côté nord
il y avait donc deux couloirs ce qui
donnait au roi deux options
ils pouvaient s'élever vers les étoiles
circumpolaire ouvert la constellation
d'orion
[Musique]
les couloirs verticaux les passages et
plus de 60 millions de tonnes de roches
faisaient tous partie de la structure de
la pyramide de qufu représente en
importance placé sur l'après vie
cette pyramide mérite bien tous les
titres qu'elle a reçu après tout il
s'agit d'un des plus grands monuments
jamais conçu par des humains on a
l'impression que le temps commence et
finit quelque part entre ces pierres
après un passage difficile à travers
cette montagne où nous avions vu la
beauté de son intérieur nous étions
contents de retrouver la lumière et
l'air pur comme si nous retrouvions la
vie pour continuer notre voyage dans la
mortalité après avoir expérimenté le
mystère de la mort charged lane 1884
[Musique]
et ensevelis dans la pyramide le pharaon
était ainsi assuré d'atteindre
l'immortalité
ce massif tombeau était son dernier
relais avant de commencer son expédition
éternelle chipie rami est un véritable
ensembles funéraires qui est constituée
non seulement de la tombe du roi mais
aussi d'une pyramide voisine servant de
temple tout en menant à la vallée du nil
et puis d'un temple de la vallée
terminant le complexe mortuaire royal
c'était un genre de gare routière
centrale pour le voyage de l'après vie
au lieu de prendre le bus vous preniez
n'importe quel moyen de transport
cosmique dont vous aviez besoin pour
voyager avec le roi soleil jusqu'aux
impérissable aux étoiles et aux diverses
destinations du roi dans l'au delà est
en fait dans le cas du complexe de la
pyramide qufu il y avait des
emplacements réservés à de vrais bateaux
en 1954 des ouvriers qui essayaient de
déblayer le bas de la grande pyramide
ont trouvé un mur qui couvrait une
cavité de trois mètres et demi de
profondeur à l'intérieur de la cavité se
trouvait du bois provenant d'arbres que
l'on ne trouve qu'au liban il y avait en
tout mille deux cent quatre morceaux de
bois datant de l'époque de qufu il a
fallu 16 ans aux archéologues pour
enlever et rassembler tous les fragments
de bois
ils ont ainsi obtenu un bateau d'une
longueur de 44 mètres qui pouvait
flotter sur l'eau
de nombreux experts pensent que ce
bateau faisait partie des funérailles de
qufu ils ne sont pas certains de l'usaj
qui lui était réservée mais il pense
qu'il était peut être destiné à
transporter les trésors qui avait été
enterrée avec le pharaon à l'intérieur
de la pyramide
après sa mort le pharaon ne perdait pas
son statut il gardait le même niveau
social dans l'au delà
cette croyance à porter le regard sur un
autre aspect de la nécropole de guizeh
[Musique]
tout autour des pyramides
on trouve beaucoup d'autres tombent sur
toute l'étendue du plateau à l'origine
ces tombes étaient des maisons de
l'éternité pour la cour du roi
[Musique]
il s'agit d'un cimetière réservé aux
militaires aux ingénieurs des mines et
de la construction aux architectes ou
trésorier aux juges et aux
fonctionnaires de justice aux
conseillers et aux ministres chacun
d'entre eux vivaient et prospérer dans
ce monde disparu
il n'aurait jamais certainement imaginer
le jour non seulement leur civilisation
aurait disparu et mais où aussi leur
langue serait devenu une langue morte
est oublié et tout cela pour ne revivre
qu'à travers les travaux de toute une
génération d'experts james hendry brest
et de 1905 la nécropole entière le
cimetière entier reflètent la fonction
de la société nous savons que le plan
des villes égyptiens se compose la
palais royal au centre qui est ensuite
entouré des maisons de la haute société
et puis en marge on trouve les gens
moins aisés il s'agit donc ici d'une
version idéalisée de la réalité de leur
vie
un genre de version monumental nous
montrant la structure des villes
les égyptiens s'assurer qu'il y a un
gardien pour la ville des défunts à la
base du plateau de gizeh se trouve une
sentinelle de pierres mystérieuses et
imposante qui symbolise cette
civilisation perdue pour l'egypte
ancienne
cela a autant de signification que les
pyramides qu'elle protège
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du côté est du bas du plateau de gizeh
en dessous du complexe des pyramides se
trouve un autre symbole de l'egypte
ancienne
le sphinx
celui qui peut supporter le regard de
pierre du sphinx seul dans le silence du
désert peut alors trouver sa propre
interprétation du mystère de la vie et
de la mort que le sphinx symbolise
peut-être artur silva ouailles historien
auteur 1899
[Musique]
cette étrange culture ou côté mystérieux
à la fois humain et animal
c'est en en face de la pyramide de
khéphren tout en gardant silencieusement
le secret de sa vraie signification
[Musique]
à guiza le sphinx reste anonyme il
n'existe aucun texte qui explique
pourquoi le sphinx a été construit et
quelles étaient les pensées de l'époque
à son sujet mais en à grandes raisons de
croire qu'il a été construit à l'époque
de khephren qui est à l'origine de la
deuxième pyramides de gizeh il est placé
un pas en arrière du temple de la vallée
et de cette façon ils gardent l'entrée
du complexe entier de la pyramide est en
fait l'entière nécropole de guizeh
[Musique]
dans l'egypte ancienne les sphinx était
traditionnellement des gardiens il
protégeait les endroits sacrés comme par
exemple les entrées des temples et de
l'au delà
vincent ce qui donne la vie la stabilité
et la puissance qui dirige la vérité et
rien sur tout les monde brille comme un
soleil pour toujours et à jamais
inscriptions les logiciels d'allant dans
nos 20 kg c d e minute par son attaquant
bdp
[Musique]
à travers les âges cette créature extra
ordinaire a donné lieu à de nombreuses
interprétations symbolique pour les
grecs
il représentait la sagesse occultes pour
les arabes de la période médiévale
il s'agissait d'abul le père de la
terreur mais au départ les experts
pensaient qu'il ne s'agissait que de la
simple utilisation de pierre qui
n'étaient plus nécessaires
il s'agit des restes d'une ancienne
carrière apparemment la pierre n'était
pas de très bonne qualité et les
égyptiens ne savait que faire de tout
cela il est probable qu au lieu
d'enlever complètement ce qui en restait
quelqu'un qui était peut-être un
sculpteur ou un artiste a proposé d'en
faire un projet
le résultat de ce projet est ce colosse
qui semble se transformer sans effort
d'un état animal à humain le sphinx à la
puissance du lion et sa tête est non
seulement une tête humaine mais aussi la
représentation d'un demi dieu
le pharaon pour un type de foulards que
seul le roi pouvait porter et le contour
du sphinx exprime l'ordre imposé par la
domination divine du monde naturel
le sphinx comme les pyramides qu'il
protège est de taille massive son corps
mesure 73 m ce qui représente plus des
trois quarts d'un terrain de football
sa tête s'élève à 20 mètres de haut
c'est à dire l'équivalent d'un bâtiment
à six étages ce monument gigantesque
évoquant à la fois un lion est le roi
devait donner l'impression aux gens de
l'époque que leur dirigeant avait la
puissance d'un dieu ou vend ainsi
posséder les forces de la nature
c'était comme si le roi pouvait émerger
de la roche
tout comme le sphinx afin de recevoir ce
qui lui est dû grâce à son rôle de
souverain qui continuent à jamais même
dans l'après vie
le sphinx à une très forte présence bien
qu'il ait subi des altérations à travers
les siècles comme son visage le reflète
au début du xvème siècle avant
jésus-christ un historien arabe expliqué
qu' un homme en colère contre les gens
qui croyaient encore au mysticisme de
l'egypte ancienne en dommages a le nez
du sphinx certains disent aussi que
napoléon aurait participé à l'altération
du monument mais selon de nombreux
égyptologues
il ne s'agit ici que de l'étrange
folklore qui entoure la créature
mystérieuse
il affirme que la destruction était
causée par l'ennemi numéro 1 de l'egypte
ancienne
le temps
[Musique]
nous voilà face au mystère silencieux du
sphinx son visage portant la marque du
temps et des intempéries surveille les
plaines et fait face au soleil levant
comme il l'a fait pendant des milliers
d'années alors que nous questionnons
toujours ses lèvres muette concernant
son âge et son origine james hendry
brest et fondateur de l'institut
oriental l'université de chicago 1905
son visage défiguré à laisser sans
réponse la question de sa ressemblance à
un personnage particulier de nombreux
égyptologue pense qu'il a été sculptée
vers 2500 avant jésus-christ pour
ressembler roi à qui la pyramide sur
laquelle il veille est dédié
on pense bien sûr que le sphinx de gizeh
représente qui freine si vous regardez
soigneusement les traits du sphinx qui
ont été préservés
vous verrez de nombreuses similarités
dans le style de sculpture avec képhren
et les rois de l'ancien empire en
particulier la forme carrée de la
mâchoire
les sourcils arqués les pommettes
saillantes ont motivé les experts à
penser que cette sculpture avait été
faite pendant la ivème dynastie
c'est à dire à l'époque des pyramides de
gizeh
pour renforcer cela le passé a rencontré
le présent grâce à la technologie en
1989 quand les égyptologues ont allié
leurs connaissances à celle de plusieurs
architectes de façon à recréer le sphinx
dans sa forme originale
ils ont comparé les traits de visage du
sphinx à ceux de khephren et ont ajouté
un nez une barbe et une coiffure toute
en utilisant une statue de l'époque
ils ont aussi utilisé un ordinateur pour
peindre le sphinx de façon électronique
comme avec un pinceau ils ont ainsi
obtenu une image complète de ce à quoi
cette statue de pierre ressembler il y à
plus de 4000 ans l'apparence du sphinx
ne représente qu'un aspect de la
datation l'immense statue effet d'une
série de couches calcaires les
fondations formant la couche de base
sont en calcaire dur alors que la couche
du milieu qu'on tient alternativement du
calcaire durée du calcaire mouche pour
se terminer par du calcaire dur la tête
a été sculptée dans de la pierre dure de
construction ce qui a permis de la
conserver plus intacte que le reste du
corps
l'ensemble des pierres a donné lieu à de
nombreux débats
certains pensent que le sphinx était
construit neuf mille ans avant
jésus-christ mais de nombreux égyptiens
pensent que certains éléments
archéologiques vont à l'encontre de
cette évaluation
[Musique]
il est entouré par des centaines peut
être des milliers de tombes par des
pyramides des passages des bateaux des
statuts qui ressemble à ce que l'on
trouve à l'époque de qufu de khephren et
demain corps et le lieu
le contexte la position dans le contexte
général de l'architecturé de l'art
égyptien suggère que la construction
date de la ivème dynastie et sa place
dans le complexe de khephren indique que
ce dernier est à l'origine du projet
c'est sur ce genre d'éléments que les
théories ont été établies le sphinx
semble être à sa place ici son apparence
complète le paysage de façon harmonieuse
dans cet endroit le côté spirituel
domine c'est comme si la roche exprimait
elle même le génie le mip et le mystère
qui entoure ces monuments les grandioses
pyramide se baigne dans la brume qui
amène les ombres de la nuit à leurs
pieds
petit à petit elles deviennent moins
tangible le silence nous envoûte encore
plus et nous emportons loin
[Musique]
artur silva wife 1899
le sphinx représentent les capacités
créatrices incroyable des égyptiens de
l'antiquité le plateau de gizeh reflète
leur talent c'est là qu'ils ont su
transformer le désert et sculpter un
tableau de pierre qui durera à jamais
[Musique]
tout est en équilibre plus précisément
c'est ce qu'on appelle en harley qui
vibre informel l'ensemble ne peut être
une coïncidence
cela a demandé de la planification et
chaque roi après coup fou a ajouté sa
participation tout en respectant la
ligne non architectural déjà établi par
son père ou son grand père
la structure de gizeh témoigne d'une
volonté de cohérence
pour les gens de l'époque la création du
sphinx était bien plus qu'une simple
améliorations architecturales
l'emplacement se trouve le sphinx semble
mettre en évidence leur décision de
sculpter ce bloc de pierre qui leur
restait pour une raison bien
particulière quand les égyptiens ont
décidé de construire à une échelle
monumentale d'une certaine façon c'était
pour eux comme d'inscrire des
hiéroglyphes sur des hectares entiers
il ne faisait pas vraiment de
distinction entre l' architecture
l'écriture est l'heure pour eux tout
était hiéroglyphique le sphinx est donc
ainsi un hiéroglyphe gigantesque
selon les experts le sphinx qui est
placé un peu vers le bas et sur le côté
tout en étant centré entre les pyramides
peut être lu comme un hiéroglyphe g1 les
deux pyramides forme une sorte de cadre
pour la tête de la créature
certains pensent que les gens de
l'époque voyait peut-être la tête comme
un disque s'élevant entre deux montagnes
les experts pensent que sa situation par
rapport aux pyramides était comme une
représentation du lever du soleil
bien après sa construction le sphinx est
apparu dans les inscriptions égyptienne
sous le nom de aurait maquettes ou aux
russes dans l'horizon les experts
pensent que cette théorie est en accord
avec les croyances religieuses en
existence durant la construction du
complexe des pyramide de khéphren en
2500 avant jésus-christ à cette époque
le culte du dieu soleil était déjà bien
développé le sphinx et ses structures
alentours dont le temple placé entre ses
pattes met l'accent sur cette croyance
à l'origine ce temple possédait 24
piliers de granit qui entourait la cour
les experts pensent que ces piliers
représentaient les 12 heures de la
journée et les 12 heures de la nuit
[Musique]
on a pu constater que durant le coucher
du soleil au milieu de l'année
astronomique la pyramides et le sphinx
forme une silhouette unique
c'est alors que le soleil brille sur le
temple au dessus de la partie ouest du
toit jusqu'au sanctuaire situé à alès ce
qui symbolise le soleil levant il
illumine une image représentant le
soleil levant comme une préfiguration de
son lever pendant le voyage dans l'au
delà
le sphinx et son temple tout comme les
pyramides sont considérés comme des
merveilles de créativité mais pour les
gens de l'antiquité il était bien plus
que cela
le côté créatif de la construction
n'était pas central pour les gens de
l'époque ce qu'il voulait c'était de
maintenir l'ordre établi l'ordre divin
et il voulait que tout continue de la
même manière
le pharaon l'homme dieu qui était en
charge de l'endroit pouvait changer de
forme tout comme le dieu horus
représenté par un faucon il pouvait
devenir le dieu soleil ray dans tous ses
aspects et ensuite ils pouvaient se
transformer à l'image d'un lion puissant
tout cela pour aider à assurer la
sauvegarde du style de vie de l'egypte
ancienne
[Musique]
lorsque la civilisation a changé
l'importance du sphinx symboles sacrés
des gens de la ivème dynastie a disparu
aiguisait a été abandonnée
cette statue de taille imposante est
devenu la victime du même plateau
qu'elle avait jadis protéger puis au
xvème siècle avant jésus-christ un homme
a trouvé cette énorme objets enveloppé
de sable selon la légende gip sienne le
sphinx a commencé à communiquer des
renseignements de valeur qui permettrait
à l'homme de devenir roi
[Musique]
les pyramides et le sphinx ont été
construits entre 2575 et 2465 avant
jésus-christ durant la période de
l'ancien empire l'écroulement de
l'empiré en 2150 avant jésus-christ a
marqué la fin de la gloire du plateau de
gizeh des siècles plus tard la
civilisation s'est rétablie et a
instauré le moyen empire mais l'air de
la construction de la grande pyramide
était bien terminée et 500 ans plus tard
le moyen empire s'écroula aussi
pendant plus de mille ans on a abandonné
ses édifices sacrés aux sables du désert
leur gardien était même recouvert de
sable c'est grand triangle n'étaient
plus des symboles du chemin qui mène aux
cieux il était à présent comme des
signaux de quelques erreurs synonymes
d'abondance trésor
en théorie la nécropole était un endroit
déclaré hors limite elle était
considérée comme sacrée et supérieur et
les gens n'étaient pas censés y aller
mais les cimetières étaient abandonnées
comme des villes fantômes et les gens
ont commencé à s'y introduire et à en
extraire les trésors pour les gens de
l'antiquité le pillage des tongs
présenter un problème sérieux est allé à
l'encontre de leurs croyances
en détruisant la tombe on tuait le
défunt dans l'après vie c'était donc un
des crimes les pires au monde et
particulièrement s'il s'agissait de la
tombe d'un roi les rois étaient des demi
dieux et des représentants des dieux il
était en charge de maintenir l'ordre
établi il est donc difficile d'imaginer
un crime plus de dieu que de piller les
tombes royales d'une civilisation si
fermement centré sur sa morale
religieuse
au 16ème siècle avant jésus-christ
environ mille ans après la construction
des monuments de guizeh le nouvel empire
comment ça c'était l'âge d'or de
l'egypte les gens célébrer la puissance
de leur monarchie et espérait encore
garder leur style de vie dans l'au delà
on a ainsi abandonné la construction des
normes monuments funéraires la forme
pyramidale était toujours symbolique
mais les pillages avaient motivé les
gens à trouver un endroit plus secret
pour leur cimetière à plus de 675
kilomètres de gizeh en aval du nil est
en face de la capitale égyptienne de
l'époque
taib on pensait avoir trouvé le site
recherché l'endroit a évoqué la création
et suivait la mythologie il y avait là
une colline s'élevant sur la vallée des
rois
[Musique]
de la vallée des rois on peut voir une
pyramide de pierre situé au sommet d'une
montagne la montagne sacrée qui
surplombe le cimetière dans ce cas une
seule pyramide de grande taille est
utilisé pour tous les rois les rois sont
à présent enterré sur le flanc de la
montagne dans des tongs qui sont
quelquefois profondément inséré dans le
sol sans marque externe particulière
sauf une entrée dans un sens les tombes
du nouvel empire sont devenus moins
accessible qu'auparavant
[Musique]
de nombreux pharaons ont été enterrés
ici et leurs momies survivent toujours
[Musique]
on y trouve toutankhamon l'enfant roi
ramsès deux plus connus sous le nom de
ramsès legrand et sethi 1er le père de
ramsès 2 tous ces pharaons dont les
momies ont été préservés faisait parti
du puissant nouvel empire
c'était une aire d'excavation et de
restauration pour de nombreux monuments
anciens on a soudain redonner vie à ces
structures et le sphinx a été
redécouvert
les roi de la xviiième dynastie étaient
les premiers à régner parmi eux on
trouve toutes nos 6 4 le premier a
délivré le sphinx du sable qui
l'entouraient
un jour le fils du roi tout mon fils
était allé à la chasse à midi et s'était
ensuite reposer à l'ombre de ses grands
dieux et il a expliqué que le sphinx
était couvert de sable à peu près
jusqu'au cou le sphinx lui apparu en
rêve comme le dieu de la royauté
attoumgbré et le roi soleil dans tous
ses aspects et a dit tout mon fils
regarde moi regarde moi tout mon fils
mon fils je suis ton père aux russes
dans l'horizon est prêt à tomber je te
promets un taux de diriger tout ce qui
est vivant sur terre tous les
territoires sur lesquels mail du soleil
se pose seront catoire vers toi je
tourne mon visage et mon coeur pour
avoir la protection puisque je suis
malade dans tous mes membres les sables
de l'endroit sacré sur lequel je repose
m'ont refoulé vers le texte dit mes
membres sont malades
réveille-toi des livres - du désert de
sable et cela implique que je te rendrai
roi d'égypte et malheureusement le texte
est rodé au moment de dire oui et je le
ferai
de toute évidence il a dégagé le sphinx
du sable et a reçu le royaume promis les
générations suivantes ont inscrit qu'il
a obtenu le trône grâce à un oracle
divin
james hendry braastad 1905
tout mot six a dit que le sphinx aurait
fait un accord avec lui et que le grand
dieu qui habitaient la statue l'avait
largement repayer il est intéressant de
remarquer que durant l'époque du
soi-disant rêve tout mocistes n'était
pas prétendant au trône
les experts se pose donc des questions
au sujet de sa prémonition et de sa
venue au pouvoir il ya un aspect
politique dans tout cela parce qu'il a
tué son frère aîné qui devait être roi
d'égypte et c'est donc pour cette raison
qu'il a inventé cette histoire afin de
montrer que le dieu aurait maquettes aux
russes de l'horizon l'avait choisi pour
devenir roi d'égypte on peut trouver la
conversation entre tout mot si c'est le
sphinx sur une tablette placé
directement au dessous de sa poitrine
en dépit de l'aspect politique de
l'histoire
la tablette contient le rapport
archéologique le plus ancien fait par un
roi sur l'état de ruines du sphinx
l'inscription se lit comme un rapport
d'événement et cela a donc permis aux
archéologues d'examiner la motivation
d'un homme et ses actions en découlant
[Musique]
on a fait un nouveau type de parc
national royal autour du sphinx avec des
petites maisons en briques destiné aux
pharaons
et puis on a ensuite restauré le support
de pierre du sphinx c'était le premier
projet de restauration du sphinx devenu
ainsi un des symboles nationaux de
l'egypte toutes nos 6 4 avait donc
ravivé le paysage le plateau de gizeh et
est devenue une merveille de l'antiquité
même pour ceux de l'époque tout mon fils
avait généreusement garder la promesse
faite au sphinx
il avait dégagé et restaurer cette
statue antique et avaient construit des
murs pour la protéger il a ensuite fini
la restauration en ajoutant de la
couleur au monument
[Musique]
dans l'antiquité égyptienne il était
très commun de peindre les statuts il
était de rigueur de ne pas laisser la
pierre nue comme nous l'apprécions
aujourd'hui et pouvons la voir dans de
nombreux musées mais de la peindre avec
des couleurs très vives le fait de
peindre la statue la rendait vivante une
fois encore des égyptologues et des
architectes se sont concertés pour créer
une image peinte en relief du sphinx
[Musique]
les égyptologues ont pu recueillir les
renseignements nécessaires en observant
les traces de peinture trouvé sur le
sphinx et d'autres statues égyptiennes
également peintes
ils ont ainsi obtenu une créature
majestueuse reflétant la pensée de
l'époque
si vous en étiez vous même le peintre
vous ne seriez pas de montrer le visage
d'un homme à la quarantaine cinquantaine
soixantaine ou même à un âge particulier
le but n'est pas de faire un portrait
mais d'obtenir une image idéalisée du
roi habillé de ses plus beaux atours
comme pour aller à un bal mais dans ce
cas au lieu d'aller à un bal
il va à l'événement le plus élégant et
le plus important de tous les temps il
va à la rencontre des dieux
pour les egyptiens le sphinx était une
image idéalisée de dieu et de l'homme
il était le gardien du plateau et un
médiateur qui existait sur la terre des
vivants et dans le monde des défunts
[Musique]
l'egypte de l'époque accordé souvent
plus d'une fonction à ses créations
le sphinx n'était pas une exception à
cela
[Musique]
d'après certains égyptologues le gardien
de granit du plateau de gizeh aurait eu
un but plus élevé que celui de protéger
les pyramides et de regarder le soleil
égyptiens se lever pendant toute
l'éternité
je pense que le sphinx était un moyen
d'établir un dialogue entre les vivants
et les morts
le sphinx son temps peut former un genre
de site limin elle c'est à dire un seuil
entre le monde terrestre et l'étrangeté
de l'au delà
le sphinx semble ignorer le désert qui
se trouve à ses pieds son regard se
porte vers l'horizon le seuil de
l'inconnu l'entrée du monde spirituel
tout un rêve est enfermé dans cette
pierre arthur sylvain white historien
auteur 1899
[Musique]
une croyance égyptienne a pris naissance
dans la sculpture du suspense
[Musique]
la statue était destiné à représenter le
pharaon des fins grâce à elle ils
pouvaient de l'au-delà influencé la vie
quotidienne de son peuple
le concept de l'art pour l'art
n'existait pas chez les égyptiens toutes
les statues avaient un but
elle était habitée par une âme qui
pouvait aller et venir et être la
personne représentée on trouvait des
statuts pour les esprits dans les tombes
elles étaient similaires aux momies et
été à l'image du défunt mais sous une
forme idéalisée elle était souvent
visibles contrairement aux momies qui
était bien protégé
le jour des funérailles on fermait le
tombeau du défunt aucune personne
vivante ne pouvait entrer dans la pièce
qui était réservé à l'âme du défunt
alors les statuts funéraire remplaçaient
les momies la famille les amis et dans
les cas des rois les suivants loyaux
pouvait ainsi rendre hommage au défunt
et apporter des aliments en offrande les
égyptiens pouvait voir que les offrandes
qu'ils apportaient restée intacte aucune
âme ne venait les consommer et on
pourrait donc se demander pourquoi ils
continuer à faire ce rituel
sachant que le corps humain a besoin
d'être nourris pour ne pas mourir
ils pensaient que leurs offrandes
n'était pas de la nourriture pour le
corps mais donnait une sorte de force de
vie que l'âme pouvait extraire afin de
continuer à vivre
ayant été ainsi nourrit l'âme du défunt
se trouvant à l'intérieur de la statue
funéraire pouvait alors accorder des
bénédictions aux visiteurs les statuts
étaient sacrés et comme les momies elle
faisait l'objet de rituel accompli par
des prêtres avant d'enfermer la momie
dans son tombeau on laissait le corps du
défunt a allongé devant ses statuts ou
en face du cercueil qui servait de
statut
c'était à ce moment-là que le rite
funéraire le plus important était
accomplie la cérémonie de l'ouverture de
la bouche
[Musique]
la cérémonie de l'ouverture de la bouche
avait pour but de permettre à l'âme omis
de dire les formules importante qui
était nécessaire à son arrivée dans l'au
delà
on touchait la bouche avec un ustensile
religieux et on disait vous retrouvez la
jeunesse vous revivez vous retrouvez la
jeunesse ta bouche des clauses j'ouvre
pour toi ta bouche
j'ouvre pour toi tes deux yeux le défunt
marchera et parlera et son corps sera en
compagnie des dieux et d'adoum vieillard
formule de l'egypte ancienne la momie
pourra donc parler dans l'au delà et
réciter les formules magiques qui lui
permettront de ressusciter mais la momie
n'était pas le seul objet de l'attention
des prêtres durant la cérémonie
quand la cérémonie était terminée les
statues étaient prêts à servir de
remplacement pour le corps pendant toute
l'éternité
vous gardiez votre propre forme vous
étiez plus qu'un esprit et votre énergie
ne pouvait pas entrer dans une autre
personne la réincarnation par le biais
de la statue ou de l'identité de
quelqu'un d'autre n'était pas possible
c'est pour cette raison que les
égyptiens étaient si déterminé à faire
des statuts des gens pour avoir un
symbole visuel des individus ces
symboles visuels contenait l'âme du
défunt qui devait pouvoir aller d'un
monde à l'autre
les égyptiens sont assurés en faisant
une niche directement dans le mur du
tombeau
la niche était comme une fausse porte
qui pour les égyptiens de l'époque
représentait un passage c'était à la
fois l'entrée et la sortie entre le
monde des vivants et celui des morts
vous avez permis à mon âme et un nombre
de marchés sur leurs pieds jusqu'à
l'endroit où se trouve cette personne de
façon à ce qu'ils puissent lever
s'asseoir est entré dans sa chapelle de
l'éternité
parce que je suis de l'entourage
d'osiris qui voyagent la nuit et revient
le jour et aucun dieu ne peut être créé
quand je suis silencieux formule de
l'egypte ancienne
[Musique]
il existe une tombes dont le
propriétaire avait sculpté sa propre
image sortant de la fausse porte avec
les bras ouverts pour recevoir des
offrandes ce genre d'image frontale
renforce l'idée du défunt qui ressuscite
comme la momie mais à travers la statue
et non d'une façon littérale
je pense que le sphinx est comparable au
statut des tombeaux à cause des éléments
architecturaux qui l'entourent
la seule manière de voir le sphinx et de
manière frontale
le sphinx présente donc une image
frontale avec son propre temple placé à
l'avant où on faisait les offrandes aux
dieux soleil et au roi pour les gens du
nouvel empire cette statue partageaient
leur réalité ainsi que celle de
l'au-delà pour le pharaon le sphinx et
ses alentours joue un rôle dans les
cérémonies rituelles
[Musique]
c'était devenu un endroit où les rois
durant la première année de leur règne
et il leur arrivait au trône venait être
ordonnées dans ce lieu symbole de
royautés et du dieu à tous mais il
accédait ainsi au trône se plaçant à la
tête de la famille royale
ce symbole antique de la royauté a
acquis une position de pouvoir aux yeux
des gens pendant 2000 ans mais l'egypte
se préparait encore a changé et le sable
brûlant et serrait encore d' étouffer
l'esprit de cette statue sacré
[Musique]
l'egypte a été appelée le don du nil et
pour la période de l'antiquité
c'était un nom reflétant la réalité pour
les nations voisines elles
représentaient une perle rare qu'il
convoitait et qu'ils causent à de
nombreuses guerres en dépit des efforts
faits à invoquer les dieux divers les
pharaons n'ont pas pu empêcher le déclin
de leur civilisation
après 2000 ans l'ordre était compromis
et un chaos général était prêt à
s'installer dans le pays
[Musique]
les perses ont été les premiers
envahisseurs à prendre le contrôle du
pays en 525 avant jésus-christ ils ont
ensuite été suivis en 332 avant
jésus-christ par alexandre legrand qui a
intégré l'egypte dans l' empire grecque
et puis on a vu l'arrivée des romains la
fin du style de vie de l'egypte ancienne
et est proche car les grecs et les
romains n'ont montré que pour peu de
temps un intérêt pour le culte religieux
égyptien
[Musique]
durant la période gréco romaine le
monument a subi quelques changements
les romains ont rajouté une couche
supplémentaire au support du sphinx en
plus des couches déjà existantes fragile
qui avait été en partie à éroder les
grecs mentionne dans des inscriptions le
fait que certains empereurs romains
prêtait attention aux facs il y avait
une sorte de cycle de l'intérêt porté à
la statue 5000 ans plus tard le monument
servait à nouveau de symbole national
le renouvellement du sphinx durera
pendant quelque temps mais sa
signification deviendra mystérieuse les
croyances du passé était submergé par
des influences étrangères dès le 2e
siècle après jésus-christ le sphinx fait
partie de ces symboles qui défiait la
compréhension humaine
ce n'était déjà plus une construction
faite par les humains pour un roi mais
plutôt une création des dieux
trafford audacieuse et le travail des
dieux immortels pour protéger ce pays
plat et fertile
ils t'ont placé à cet endroit comme une
île rocheuse où ils ont battu lausanne
ils t'ont placez au frais des pyramides
servir leurs seins qui veille avec
vigilance sur osiris le béné
inscriptions ancien 2e siècle après
jésus-christ
suivant le cycle de restauration et de
renouvellement le sphinx tombera encore
dans l'oubli la prépondérance de la
théologie chrétienne a donc commencé à
dominer la civilisation égyptienne et
les croyances d'origine qui avait donné
naissance aux momies et aux monuments
ont été écartés ce déclin a eu lieu
durant le quatrième siècle alors qu'on
fermait et détruisaient les temples les
derniers hiéroglyphes ont été inscrits
et cette culture antique centré sur le
pouvoir du pharaon a finalement pris fin
le lion à tête humaine la créature
représentant les dieux est le roi le
sphinx a dû aussi traversé l'époque de
destruction ils étaient couverts de
sable jusqu'au cou abandonner encore une
fois l'étreinte brûlante du désert des
640 après jésus-christ l'egypte est une
nation arabe n était plus un empire la
signification des monuments
spectaculaire des structures massives et
des momies soigneusement enveloppé
s'était évanoui les croyances qui avait
été à la base de ces images
impressionnantes avait disparu il
semblait que l'ennemi numéro 1 de
l'antiquité le temps avait finalement
remporté la victoire
la civilisation avait disparu
au cours du temps les symboles antique
comme le sphinx sont devenus mystérieux
et même les traces de peinture encore
évidente sur le visage de la créature
n'apportait aucun éclaircissement sur sa
signification
[Musique]
à quelques pas de ces pyramides se
trouve une tête et un cou gigantesque
émergent du sol
on dit que le corps auquel la tête
appartient est enterrée dans le sable
sur le visage
on peut distinguer une teinte rougeâtre
et un vernis rouge qui a l'air aussi
brillant que si on venait de l'appliquer
le visage est d'une beauté remarquable
particulièrement la bouche on dirait que
le personnage sourit doucement
abdulatif médecins arabes 1200 après
jésus-christ
le sphinx et les monuments qui l'avait
protégé si vaillamment pendant des
milliers d'années n'était à présent plus
sacré la raison de leur construction
n'était plus qu'un souvenir effacés mais
cependant il servirait à un autre but
ils deviendront le point de départ de la
construction de l'egypte moderne
ces monuments ainsi que le sphinx enfoui
dans le sable connaîtront un autre
moment déterminant quand une bataille
aura lieu dans leurs alentours
un jeune général corse venait de
remporter la victoire et son invasion
aura des conséquences durables
ce général se nommait napoléon bonaparte
en napoléon est arrivé en egypte en 1798
il a accompli une conquête militaire
mais il a aussi amené avec lui des
savants et des chercheurs pour explorer
le pays et ses monuments et en fait
c'était napoléon qui a fait découvrir
l'égypte ancienne à l'europe
une des plus importantes découvertes
faites durant l'invasion française a été
celle d'une stèle de rock noir qui sera
plus tard connu sous le nom de pierre de
rosette et en 1822 elle deviendra
l'artefact qui rompra un silence 2500
ans mais cela n'apporte rien au sphinx
qui restent à enterrer jusque dans les
années 1920 on a pris plus de 10 ans
pour enlever le sable et les excavations
continue toujours aujourd'hui alors que
les archéologues réparé restera encore
une fois l'antique statut ils sont à la
recherche de renseignements enterré
quelque part dans sa longue histoire
de nombreuses questions restent sans
réponse
le sphinx fait partie d'une énigme créé
il y à bien longtemps par les gens de
l'antiquité
[Musique]
les égyptiens de l'antiquité ont laissé
derrière eux leurs momies leurs
monuments majestueux leur stature
imposante et bien plus encore ils ont
aussi laissé un système d'écriture
pittoresque qui exprimaient leurs
espoirs leurs rêves et leurs craintes
ce qu'ils essayaient de dire est resté
un mystère pendant des milliers d'années
jusqu'au moment où napoléon a entamé une
bataille dans les limites de cette
étendue abandonné c'est à cette époque
là que l'on a pu ouvrir la porte du
passé
alors que le voyage s'achève écouter les
murmures enfouies profondément dans les
inscriptions sacré les hiéroglyphes
[Musique]
trouvez l'au-delà imaginaire et
découvrez comment les gens de
l'antiquité pensaient qu'ils pouvaient y
parvenir en utilisant de mystérieuse
carte routière explorer ensuite la
signification des trésors trouvés dans
la tombe de toutankhamon et apprenez
l'histoire cachée de la malédiction
visitez dès aujourd'hui le tombeau le
plus mystérieux et le plus célèbre cave
et 5
[Musique]
tout cela et plus encore dans la suite
de notre programme des momies et les
secrets des cryptes égyptienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]